[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltreiche gibt ein brot rezept und zwar
werde ich einen roggen dinkel
sauerteigbrot backen
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht wie
kommt die zelle zum brotbacken oder
zuerst mal wohl über können habe ich
behaupte mal ein paar auch ein baguette
und so weiter aber ich habe jetzt vor
kurzem mit die hefe selber hergestellt
das heißt es hefe wasser und habe ja
gesagt dass er jetzt ein paar brot
rezepte gibt auch das thema pro zimmer
gestoßen als wir auf der messe waren und
also wir sind auf vielen messen aber es
war eben auf einer messe und da habe er
sein leben wolfgang kennengelernt da
wolfgang darstellt mühlen her
das heißt für körner für weizen gerste
und so weiter und hat eben hier
diesellok mittelmühle gemacht wo ich so
erfinder der minister erinnerte wolfgang
pinner der mühle und ja so sind wir zu
dem thema getreide mahlen gekommen und
haben auch dort den partner
kennengelernt der plot er macht richtig
volle prot rezepte und er hat mir
sozusagen das backen mit dem hefe wasser
so ein bisschen beigebracht denn
normalerweise habe ich immer mit
industrie hilfe gebacken werde ich auch
weiterhin natürlich zum beispiel beim
stop oder so mal tun wobei ich jetzt
auch schon den muss auf mit dem hefe
wasser angesetzt habe und es ist auch
wirklich richtig gut
das backen mit dem hefe wasser habe ich
euch in den letzten video schon ein
bisschen erläutert was für vorteile hat
eben dass man das brot viel besser
verträgt und wirklich einfach gar nicht
mehr angewiesen auf die industriellen
hefe würfeln und hier haben wir das
erste boot auf meinem kanal und zwar ist
das dinkel roggen sauerteigbrot und ja
die körner habe ich selbst gemahlen das
hat gewisse vorteile
ihr könnt natürlich auch vollkommen medi
im supermarkt kaufen da gibt es ja
wirklich alle möglichen variationen
trocken dinkel weizen also wirklich alle
mehlsorten kaufen
der vorteil vom selber mal ist aber dass
hier einfach das volle korn habt die
körner die sind ja wirklich auch ewig
haltbar ohne dass ihr geschmack und
aroma verlieren und natürlich haben sie
auch die wertvollen werkstoffe mit dabei
die ganzen vitamine und mineralstoffe
und natürlich auch die ballaststoffe
wenn man körner selbst malt dann merkt
man dass es mehr einfach so cremig ist
das heißt es ist nicht so trocken wie
das vollkornmehl aus dem supermarkt und
es kommt einfach daher dass in den
körnern auch fette mit enthalten sind
das fertig gemahlenem mehl also das
frisch gemahlene mehl ist eben cremig
hat diese fette mit dabei und wenn das
jetzt ein bisschen länger steht dann
weiß man so wie auch bei butter wenn die
länger steht dann kann sie auch mal an
sich werden
das heißt vollkommen egal was selbst
gemahlen ist sollte man am besten auch
eben frisch verzehren und eben
weiterverarbeiten
bei dem industriellen mail ist es leider
so dass die eben länger haltbar gemacht
werden müssen sonst können die ja auch
nicht im supermarkt stehen
das heißt die stoffe die dann da drin
sind die fette zum beispiel und auch die
anderen teilweise auch wertvolle stoffe
müssen einfach vorher abgetötet werden
damit dieses mehr haltbar gemacht wird
was zur folge hat dass natürlich auch
nährstoffe mit abgetötet werden die eben
im frischen com mit enthalten sind das
alles verstanden leber morath sind wir
auch sendungen wie das hello
das ist so willi will's wissen sally
will es wissen hat alles gut
recherchiert und deswegen muss ich echt
sagen habe ich das brotbacken voll für
mich entdeckt ich bin echt seit tagen im
brot fieber und jetzt das ist jetzt das
erste rezept demnächst folgen noch ganz
viele andere rezepte und man muss
einfach dazu sagen brot aus selbst
gemahlen körner schmeckt oder selbst
gemahlenem mehl schmeckt einfach viel
viel besser wenn durch mehr zum ersten
mal dieses brot mitgebracht und selber
einfach mega bereit und natürlich sagen
pablo hatte pablo escobar ist wirklich
eine ganz ganz tolle becker sehr lustig
nur nämlich nicht mehr pablo escobar war
das ist wahrscheinlich meine zuschauer
auch nicht ja so kriminell sind wir
nicht wo angriff der mörder weste aber
egal
ja da wird richtig coole rezepte und da
hat man nämlich auch ganz viele tipps
und tricks verraten
und ja ich habe das erste brot das eine
police fragte ich wahrscheinlich das
sind doch zwei brote nein das ist ein
rezept das eine brot wurde in einer
kasten backform gebacken und das andere
in einem bug rahmen und da habe ich das
war einfach ein experiment von mir hat
es einfach mal ausprobiert und haben
aber auch gemerkt okay wenn man
brot backen möchte in einem bug rahmen
dann muss man den bug rahmen noch ein
bisschen optimieren und das habe ich
jetzt einfach mal ausprobiert und zeigt
euch das auch gleich im video
wichtig zu wissen ist dass wenn ihr brot
selbst machen möchtet ihr den teig am
vortag zubereitet und am nächsten tag
fertig packt das heißt man kann das
wirklich super in den alltag integrieren
wenn ihr sagt ich habe keine zeit ist
wirklich eine ausrede müsst euch einfach
die zeiten notiert und das ist wirklich
super einfach also wirklich keine sorgen
deswegen auch vortrag noch am tag vorher
nachher und jetzt denke ich war das
genug theorie ich hoffe ihr seid jetzt
nicht verwirrt sondern eher motiviert
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
die ich für dieses brot benötige für den
hefeteig brauche ich 350 km roggen
vollkornmehl 240 km dinkel vollkornmehl
350 gramm hefe wasser 150 gramm warmes
wasser und 14 grad für das leckere
rocken dinkelbrot werde ich jetzt heute
erstmal den sauerteig und dem vortag
zubereiten
damit ich das ganze zu bereiten kann
muss ich natürlich erst einmal das korn
mahlen
das macht das jetzt hier mit der
getreidemühle ich nehme jetzt zuerst mal
die rocken können die kommen jetzt hier
oben kann jetzt die mühle ganz fein
einstellen
und jetzt könnt ihr das zu und kann im
prinzip schon mal
[Musik]
die klappe hier kann ich einfach so ein
bisschen ausschütteln
dann kommt der rest auch noch raus und
im prinzip könnte ich jetzt die schüssel
einfach weiter verwenden um meinen
sauerteig anzusetzen sich dabei um
füllen damit ich gleich noch die
glasschüssel einfach unter der maschine
habt da sieht man einfach besser durch
das heißt das ist jetzt nur zur kamera
zwecken
also bevor das mich weiter verarbeitet
müsst ihr auf jeden fall mal die
geruchs- und die gefühls probe machen
frisch gemahlenes mehl fühlt sich echt
ganz ganz toll an also man merkt auch so
diese kleinen stücke aber ganz ganz
freien richtig teuer komme vor allem
rechtsgut es gibt leider noch keine the
box youtube aber ihr glaubt mir das
einfach hat man viel viel mehr geschmack
als mit fertig gekauft um vollkornmehl
da nehme ich jetzt führt den sauerteig
meine tiefe meine hilfe da habe ich
jetzt mein hefe wasser bereits angesetzt
dafür gibt es auch schon ein video und
hier an dieser flasche könnte jetzt ganz
schön sehen dass sich hier unten was
absetzt das heißt bevor ich jetzt hier
350 gramm entnehme weil ich das ganze
kurz durchschütteln einfach damit sich
es gut verbindet und kann jetzt 350
gramm abmessen und hier mit dem
roggenmehl dazu
ganz vorsichtig öffnen da kommt jetzt
viel chance wenn jetzt so stark
geschüttelt habt einfach wegen der daten
[Musik]
die daten findet ihr übrigens dann auch
einfach entfernen die brauchte jetzt
nicht mehr
jetzt kommt die hefe hier mit rein und
das ganze müsste jetzt einfach kurz mit
der hand oder zum beispiel mit einem
kochlöffel verrühren bis einfach das
komplette mail mit dem hebel wasser
verbunden ist
[Musik]
das riecht so lecker also ich kann mich
nicht daran erinnern dass wir jemals
lecker gerochen hat arbeitsgerichts
wirklich lecker vor allem in verbindung
mit dem rock- pop- folk- und wohlgemerkt
richtig gut so da kommt jetzt ein deckel
drauf jetzt werde ich noch denke
vollkommen den hersteller und du weißt
ich nehme wieder die körner gegen die
schüssel hier wieder drunter und kann
wieder auf einmal so wenn man kurz
ausschütten
und das finde ich das dinkelvollkornbrot
und salz zu fügen und werdet so einen
vorteil herstellen
[Musik]
der vortrag muss jetzt abgedeckt werden
den kann ich jetzt hier drin lassen
aber ihr kennt mich ich brauche auf
jeden fall noch mal in der rührschüssel
deswegen werde ich das ganze jetzt
umfüllen tag später bestimmt noch kuchen
oder so und kann das jetzt hier abdecken
und jetzt kann ich den vorteig und auch
den sauerteig einfach bei raumtemperatur
für etwa 18 stunden stehen lassen und
morgen dann das leckere brot backen so
sehen jetzt die teige nach der garzeit
aus sie habe ich meinen rocken sauerteig
und meinen dinkel vorteil
und jetzt wird alles verbunden das ist
übrigens keine goldfisch kein goldfisch
aquarium sondern eine bullische und sich
auf den teig gestern da rein gefüllt
damit ihr schön sehen könnte wie er
aussieht also man sich zitate aus dem
social diese poren bildung und ja das
war mich jetzt alles das heißt der
vortrag und der sauerteig werden jetzt
vermengt und der vortrag der schon ein
bisschen fester deswegen ist am besten
echt mit der hand also ab dem zeitpunkt
jetzt wird das brot fertig ist noch mal
drei stunden
das heißt ich möchte dass kunst durch
was wir zur stunde geben dann fühle ich
in den reformen lasse ich noch mal
bestimmen begehen und dann wieder noch
mal eine stunde gebacken
das heißt wenn ihr euer brot zum
beispiel sonntags morgens um acht essen
möchte der ist sonntagmorgen zum 8 gut
wenn wir kinder haben die stehen so
frühauf aber wer eben sonntagmorgen zum
essen möchte der muss eben um 5 kurz
aufstehen das kurz durch mischen kann er
ins bett und dann um sechs aufstehen
einfach kurz einfüllen da kann man noch
mal ins bett mit den kindern kuscheln
und dann kamen aus den ofen schieben in
der zeit das frühstück vorbereiten und
dann dieser perfekt oder wieder mouras
sagen würde ich es einfach als zum
abendbrot
der teig ist jetzt gut durchgemischt und
das merkt man einfach wenn die festeren
stücke weg sind jetzt werde ich ihn
abdecken für eine stunde aufgehen lassen
und dann kommt er in die backform jetzt
ist der teig soweit ich sehe auch
einfach richtig schöne form bekommen und
jetzt wird er in eine kastenform
eingefüllt ich nehme jetzt dafür einfach
so einen kleinen bug rahmen und die form
werde ich jetzt ein spiel mit etwas
bakterien spray öl liegt natürlich auch
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der teig hinein
jetzt habe ich den teig eingefüllt wie
ein glas zu streichen die einfach die
hände die vorher etwas nass machen und
jetzt hier außen sozusagen verfügen dh
außen einmal am rand entlang
[Musik]
dann einmal die oberfläche glätten
und noch einmal den rand und dann haben
wir eine richtig schöne glatte
oberfläche
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich ja an der oberfläche
einen wasserfilm und die hilft natürlich
dabei dass der teig gibt es einfach
nicht ausdrucken
hierzu werde ich das burg ab das brot
abdecken entschuldigung dialekt und wenn
es noch mal für ein bis eineinhalb
stunden aufgehen lassen und danach fest
gebacken
[Musik]
das protest aus als wäre ich jetzt
machen wir den finger setzt das heißt
wenn finger befürchten jetzt einfach
ganz ganz leicht testen und ihr seht ja
jetzt hier die stelle die springt wieder
zurück das heißt ist brot arbeitet jetzt
noch wenn ich das jetzt so in den
backofen schieben würde dann ist da
einfach noch zu viel druck drin und das
brot platz auf das heißt ich warte es
noch mal 10 bis 15 minuten
denn dann müsste es dann dürfte es
einfach nicht mehr zurück springen und
die zeit nehme ich mir jetzt noch text
nochmal ab und dann machen wir gleich
noch mal den finger jetzt ist das wort
soweit hier der finger teststrecke jetzt
hier leicht ein und ihr seht es bleibt
jetzt auch so ein bisschen unten jetzt
kann ich das gut mit wasser gespült und
jetzt machen wir noch ein bisschen deko
drauf dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach ein
messer und ein bisschen mehl
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt das brot so in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 40 grad
für etwa 45 minuten und dann werde ich
eine probe machen und schauen ob das
produkt gut ist
[Musik]
so sieht das brot jetzt aus was mir
jetzt aufgefallen etwas brot hat
natürlich extrem viel power also der
teig und deswegen hat es die bucks ein
bisschen auseinander gedrückt das heißt
ich werde jemand
produktweiterentwicklung und oft klemm
hebel an diesen eckigen backen machen um
eben auch drin brot backen zu können
das ist jetzt nicht schlimm aber es wäre
natürlich schöner wenn das boot ein
bisschen kompakter wer das heißt dass
auch ein bisschen höher und zwar eben
nicht die breite gegangen ich lese jetzt
den rahmen und kann jetzt gleich mal die
probe machen ob das boot schon gut ist
[Musik]
normalerweise lässt sie das brot ganz
gut so wie ich hier aber hier hat sie
den teig hatte den bug raum auseinander
gedrückt dass jetzt kein bug transport
dran
deswegen geht es bereits ein bisschen
aber dass sich nicht schön das löse ich
jetzt einfach mit einem backform messer
und nur aus fehlern kann man lernen
tricks brot einmal um und klopfe jetzt
auf dem boden und es fühlt sich und
herzlich nur nicht roland das heißt es
kommt jetzt einfach nur mal ohne die
backform noch mal etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten in den ofen und wenn man darauf
klopft und wenn sie es anhört wie holz
dann ist es perfekt wir am anfang schon
erwähnt ist dieses boten ein bisschen
auseinander gegangen durch die kraft des
tages ja man könnte zum prinzip bernd
das brot draus machen
oft genug wird jetzt glaube ich deinen
sitzt der mann nämlich vorhin ohne
kamera ich scheide es wurde trotzdem an
denn es ist stressig denn hat mir besser
sie hört dass auch das hatte ich mir vor
gericht ging eine kruste und innen drin
ist es nicht und glaubt mir das buch ist
mindestens fünf tage ist es genauso weit
länger sogar als sie wirklich dass der
hammer so saftig und roggenmehl ich ja
eigentlich ein bisschen schwer zu
verarbeiten
aber das funktioniert super nova sich
eine ganze politik ist noch müsse man
wirklich den brot die möglichkeit neben
gegen der star zu sein das heißt ohne
bist irgendwo was drauf zu schmieren
irgendwie ne wurst zu holen noch die
creme oder irgendwas wirklich dass das
brot mal wirklich in die hand zu nehmen
ein glas wasser oder ein thema oder
sowas und einfach nur des namens genau
und ihr seht schon im innern also das
sieht echt richtig gut aus selbst ein
schönes brot da kann ich jetzt haben wir
ja das komische sachen sie perfekt um
eine scheibe passt immer drauf zu legen
was sagen ja aber erstmal muss man ja
sowieso wissen man hat man hört es
wahrscheinlich kann man noch mal zu ihr
man ist jetzt mit offenem mund aber gut
das tut sie haben es schon gehört ja so
verletzt und schließlich sorgte richtig
saftig und vor allem hat man da wirklich
den vollen geschmack trennen die vollen
nährstoffe mit dabei klar es gehen beim
backen die hier zur empfindlichen
nährstoffe zwar kaputt die
hitzeempfindlichen vitamine
aber es überwiegt einfach ist
überwiegend einfach die hitze
unempfindlichen vitamine und nährstoffe
und es ist einfach wirklich super lecker
und sex und colbitz auf jeden fall mal
aus und demnächst gibt es noch viele
weitere brot rezepte gerne dürft ihr
euch auch ein rezept wünschen
falls ihr rezept wünsche habt demokratie
wohl schon mal dieses pecorino grotewohl
dass ich das mache machen wir auf jeden
fall und ich bin ich jetzt ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal bis dann also ich
muß sich nicht auf nachdem du mein brot
ziegelsteinen genannter austritt aus dem
ziel statt
ja und ich nenne es brot in zukunft g20
boden und nach dem anschnitt übrigens zu
aufstellen da sind dann zwei randalierer
in der sprache mächtig sind zwei wann
der lehrer in der stadtmitte und dann
sagt der anderen zum anderen sieht man
hier ein pflasterstein brauche ich nicht
ich habe ein brot von der city bei mir
im buchser wird der normale kriminelle
in die heimat auch schnell es war nicht
hitzig
doch das war nicht schön
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
den habe ich von dir sagen uns mein
bruder geht ja wie heißt doch ali mit
murat geht es besser